the essence of libertarianism is the
primacy of the individual over the state
and absolute freedom of the individual
to make his or her own choices that's
actually also the teachings of Jesus
Christ I have come to set you free
Pope Francis widely seen as the most
charismatic head of the Catholic Church
since pope john paul ii is coming to the
united states for his first papal visit
we thought to get a sense of what this
visit means we'd asked one of his
critics and also a Roman Catholic our
good old friend and Judge Andrew
Napolitano judge thanks too much old as
in duration of friendship exactly let's
set the stage a little bit this Pope was
very intriguing character seems kind of
American to me on one sense he doesn't
embrace the trappings of office as much
as previous popes did he has a sort of
humble connection with people at the
same time kind of puts America at the
head of the neoliberal economic order
which is highly critical of him what is
the importance of this trip for him do
you see Pope Francis is a challenge and
an obstacle to traditionalists Roman
Catholics as I am I emphasize
traditionalist I wouldn't have said that
if this were pre Vatican - but post
Vatican - one must distinguish between
being Catholic and being traditional so
by traditional I mean I attend a Latin
Mass where the priest faces the altar
and where sermons are traditional
theological and philosophical statements
rather than comments on politics or
sports or the types of things one often
hears in a regular Roman Catholic Mass
today I don't know why the Pope is
coming to the United States other than
to spread an aura of goodwill about
Roman Catholicism he is so likeable and
well-liked in part by our colleagues in
the media and part by the liberal
intelligentsia in part by the silence of
traditionalists who show deference and
respect to him do you see him as sort of
sharply modernizing or bucking tradition
is he making a pretty sharp turn and
things like speeding up annulment sort
things well speeding up annulments in in
the view of this traditionalist Roman
Catholic is a rejection of his papal
role the one of the jobs of the Pope is
to preserve tradition and to protect the
sack
by speeding up annulments at the same
time as permitting ordinary confession
to absolve the sin of abortion which
Roman Catholicism has taught for four
hundred years is murder he has assaulted
matrimony for him to make an omen cease
here is a back door towards permitting
divorce and that is a direct frontal
assault on the sacrament of matrimony so
you don't like him on tradition you must
love him on economics in global one well
the Pope is the Vicar of Christ on earth
he is infallible on faith and morals
thank God it is limited to faith and
morals the Pope's views on economics are
what judges called dicta that is where a
judge in a written opinion says
something utterly unrelated to the
argument in the opinion and it is merely
his or her opinion the Pope is entitled
to his opinion on any matter of
economics it has nothing to do with
human salvation now I'm in the Ayn Rand
School of Economics I believe in no
interference in the free market by the
government I believe the only moral
commercial transactions are those that
are truly and wholly and fully voluntary
not interfered with not provoked not
even encouraged by the government the
Pope is by his own words a perónist he
is probably also a communist lowercase C
and a Marxist uppercase M who does
believe that the government ought to
control and motivate the means of
production and the means of distribution
do you think that these opinions and
given his role can do tangible harm well
of course they can do tangelo harm
because they encourage governments in
areas where there's the open interplay
of idea ideas to move away from the free
market and towards more government
control for heaven's sakes the Pope says
we can do this let's go ahead and do it
that's the type of argument which I
expect to be made in light of his
assaults on capitalism it will be a
little odd mad if he comes here next
week and directly on the floor of the
House of Representatives assaults
capitalism
what remains of capitalism in the world
exists here it would be bizarre for him
to attack it at its core man let's talk
about global warming why why shouldn't I
know you're saying that the Pope you
know has very specific and kind of
limited limited duties here enumeration
of duties here but if the Pope believes
the world is going to burn up because of
carbon in 50 years shouldn'ta Pope say
yes the Pope is entitled to say whatever
he wants but in a papal exhortation or
in an encyclical which for 2000 years
have been used for the purposes of
teaching the faithful faith and morals
that's not the place for it if the Pope
wants to say at some gathering and the
Vatican by the way I think global
warming is out of control and we want to
turn down our air conditioners he can
say that I have your condition right
right he can say that in quite frankly
who cares but when he uses the trappings
of office and when he uses the means
traditionally used by his predecessors
to teach in matters of faith and morals
it's the wrong place and sends the wrong
message it gives an aura of the
imprimatur lowercase I of the church
with respect to economic and political
activities and I don't want that and
that's not why he's the Pope I want to
talk to you about the interplay between
your own sense of Catholicism and the
return ISM you know you were talking
earlier about some of the traditions
that you embrace they're not
traditionally the kind of traditions at
a libertarian socialism brace in the
United States how does your own sense of
Catholicism inform an interplay with
your sense of libertarianism the essence
of libertarianism is the primacy of the
individual over the state and as far as
is conceivable absolute freedom of the
individual to make his or her own
choices that's actually also the
teachings of Jesus Christ I have come to
set you free now I know the devil can
quote the Scriptures to suit his
purposes but the doctrine on religious
freedom the doctrine on free will is
such that free will is the greatest gift
God gave us it is so perfect a gift that
we are free to abuse it in history and
the modern era is filled with examples
of its abuse so I see no inconsistency
between the
observation that the individual is
greater than the state and the church is
teaching on on freewill
at all but I'm also not unaware of the
church's social policy and the social
policy of the church is that I am my
brother's keeper and that I should help
my brother out I accept that and I
embrace it as long as I am free to
accept it and embrace it as long as I am
not forced to do it through the
mechanism of government judge as always
thank you so much for your very
well-informed commentary for reason TV I
am that well